[Music]
visiting the bathroom is part of the
daily human experience but occasionally
constipation strikes a condition that
causes a backup in your digestive system
the food you eat can take several days
to exit your body and for many
constipation can become chronic meaning
regularly passing lumpy hard stools
accompanied by straining what's behind
this unsettling phenomenon constipation
arises in the colon also known as the
large intestine this muscular organ is
split into four sections the ascending
transverse descending and sigmoid colon
which connects with the rectum and anus
the small intestine delivers stool
consisting of ingested food bile and
digestive juices to the large intestine
as this stool moves through the colon
the organs siphons off most of the water
it contains transforming it from liquid
to solid the longer this transmission
takes the more reabsorption occurs
resulting in increasingly solid stool
once it reaches the sigmoid colon a
final bout of reabsorption occurs before
it enters the rectum descending its
walls and telling the internal anal
sphincter to relax this is the point
where you can usually decide whether to
physically expel or retain the stool
that's regulated by the pelvic floor
muscles particularly the pube erect ælis
and external anal sphincter the pube
erect ælis forms a sling like formation
around the rectum called the anal rectal
angle and when you voluntarily relax
your external anal sphincter the stool
is finally expelled when you're
constipated however a desire to visit
the bathroom isn't enough to coax your
body into action usually there's two
factors behind this problem the stools
slow movement through the colon and/or
pelvic floor dysfunction in the first
stool moves excessively slowly through
the intestines causing / absorption of
liquid which makes the stool dry and
hard with pelvic floor dysfunction stool
becomes difficult to eliminate from the
rectum because of tightened pelvic floor
muscles or due
a pelvic organ prolapse usually through
childbirth or aging both of these
problems make the anal rectal angle more
acute and it becomes difficult to expel
waste to identify constipation precisely
researchers have developed metrics such
as the Bristol stool chart most people
who look at that chart will be able to
tell they've experienced constipation
before when you're on the toilet you
should ideally be in a squatting
position with your buttocks firmly on
the toilet seat you can elevate your
feet on a stool and lean forwards with a
straight back which straightens the anal
rectal angle and eases the passage of
waste going a day without a bowel
movement isn't necessarily cause for
alarm but if you were experiencing
chronic constipation simple dietary and
lifestyle changes like fibrous
vegetables
regular exercise abdominal massage and
six to eight cups of water per day may
help restore your daily trip to the
toilet for more ted-ed lessons that
people love to watch but are too
embarrassed to share check out this
playlist
[Music]